allez-y je vous rappelle c'est parti
qu'il y aura le gagnant affrontera
j'allais celle d'emilie le gagnant
affrontera rennes
ouais enfin sur deux points bien entendu
deux points gagnants
bravo casta chérif aidara diop baissé
parce que là ils benhaim se régaler le
départ je les perds 10 couverts comme ça
y'a plus personne attention c'est parti
à valérie tu viens là n'ont rien oui
mais non tu n'es pas du coup mais non
non non et non assise sénat même si tu
vas les personnes mais là attention
quand il m'affronte et/ou castaldi face
à gil va vous faites c'est un point et
ensuite on se rencontre avant de points
gagnants je rappelle chez vous qui est
un très beau cadeau à gagner je crois de
benjamin vous l'a dit ah non je ne
connaissais pas le cas alors il ya un
très beau cadeau a réussi en régie julie
raynaud pour nous dire que nous devions
de cadeaux il ya un smartphone à gagner
vous mettez les babas la pléiade de tpm
ph tags ou gille ou benjamin ou mois
maintenant et vous guerre partir avec un
smartphone magnifique
attention c'est parti top
bon allez bonne nuit oh
lalalalalalalalala ces sites
bravo gilles vous avez peur ou pas cyril
de green volley n'est pas celle là elle
est pas mal celle là c'est parti en 2000
ou
je crois que ça veut dire et les plus
lourdes alala à 0 merci à toi toi de
servir comme combien de points je suis
parfois tout moi non mais c'est toi le
vas-y d'opale écart encore on va pas
jouer deux points d'écart il a dû deux
fois dès qu'un problème car les arrivées
de l'effet il aimait les femmes et les
faits je les ai vus mais doivent effet
le temps c'est demain n'est pas bon et
répond à ta raison tu la sens pas je
pense qu est tien tu vois merci mon cher
c'est maintenant 1 0 se terminer le
sheikh usées perdu le point du jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais bon tout